I am very excited to announce the
release of my new book thriving in the
gig economy freelancing online for tech
professionals and entrepreneurs as the
title suggests this is a book about
selling services online on a freelance
basis but it should also have relevance
for anyone who's interested in business
and productivity or even in futurism and
the impact of technology on business and
economics if you have enjoyed any of my
content on making money online lifestyle
design staying focused or persuasion
then you should find something here and
if you're interested in going freelance
or setting up an online business as a
web developer writer or anything else or
just earning a bit of money on the side
in the evenings hopefully it will
provide you with the complete blueprint
you need to escape the nine-to-five and
create the lifestyle you want the book
also has a foreword by de gallo
I'll trade of cold fusion fame which is
awesome of him he's also writing a book
at the moment that looks absolutely
fascinating to subscribe to his channel
for more on that and it has a great
cover and design put together by my
publishers at a press I'm pretty damn
proud of it to be honest
darn proud you can buy the book on
Amazon from a press directly from Barnes
& Noble or pretty much anywhere else
links in the description down below to
give you a taste of what to expect
though I thought I'd share with you some
of the best business and productivity
tips from the book some of these can
inspire you to get started with your own
business or just be a little more
efficient in what you do currently the
many forms of the kick economy the first
thing to recognize is that the gig
economy takes many forms and the key is
getting it to work for you the term
really encompasses any type of work that
is completed on a per job or per project
basis this can include working for a
company like uber or delivery though in
those scenarios often the company's
hiring have more to gain from the
arrangement than the contractors in our
case then it means selling web design
writing or other skills online it can
also mean selling directly to the
clients with services such as personal
training coaching or even gardening
though the term is used less often to
describe a b2c operations like this at
any rate because we're going out and
finding the work rather than relying on
a single company to provide it the
balance of power is shifted in our favor
and we get to control our time and
income you can use the gig economy as
your full-time career choice and enjoy
the freedom that come
from picking job you light and skipping
those you don't you can also get
unconventional this way with how you
divide your Worth and time off for
instance I only gig four days a week
which leaves me with one day to work on
the Pioneer books and other projects but
it can also be used in many other ways
for instance you can dig part-time and
take on a part-time job or you can gig a
little in the evenings in order to bring
in extra cash if you have kids and one
of you is forced to take extended leave
to look after them digging online could
be a great way to make up for that lost
income while being a full-time mom or
dad of course it's ideal if you're
someone who enjoys traveling and you
want to work on the road this is what a
digital Nomad is gigging can be used to
raise funds to pursue other dream jobs
or projects or to fill out your
portfolio and CV the key then is to
identify what you're good at what skills
you have and then in what way you're
going to sell those skills in order to
support the kind of lifestyle you want
this is our aim and I go into a lot more
depth regarding lifestyle design in the
book packaging your services so start
with the lifestyle you want or your end
goals and then design your getting
around to that know how much you need to
earn what hours you want to work whether
you need to be able to work on the road
and whether you'd rather have lots of
clients or just a few steady ones now
decide on what you're going to offer and
package that service in the way that
suits you you can even offer multiple
packages with different pricing tiers if
you're selling writing services for
instance is up to you with you charge
per word per 500 words a blog post per
hour
or for a set of blog posts ordered on a
recurring monthly basis perhaps maybe
you want to sell website starter packs
with 200 blog posts at a discounted rate
each has its pros and cons and each will
suit different lifestyles try to agree
how many revisions are going to offer at
that price how much communication is
included whether you provide formatting
or perhaps whether this incurs of
slightly steeper fee the more you
outline in your offering the less
confusion there will be and the more you
can fine-tune your own workflow process
fixes in the book I talked about
increasing focus and for activity by
creating the right working environment
and even using flow hacks I also discuss
using technology in software as force
multipliers to help you produce more
work with the same amount of effort but
one of my favorite strategies comes from
my wife's work the process fix
that means looking at any routine
process that you're using your workflow
and finding ways to make it more
efficient for instance I used to write
blog posts and then proofread them and
upload them to WordPress then I'd add
the formatting and the images now though
I instead do the proofread at the same
time as the formatting and adding the
images essentially removing one of the
steps and thereby saving myself up to 10
to 20 minutes per blog post seeing as
I'm getting paid per job that represents
a rather huge increase in my overall
salary and this is what's really
interesting here at the gig economy
thereby becoming more efficient yourself
you can increase your wages without
actually changing the amount that you're
charging anyone in the book I also
talked about how to negotiate higher
rates even a tiny increase per word can
translate to huge pay rises that you'd
never be able to accomplish in
traditional employment look at each
stage in your workflow in-depth and ask
if it could be made more efficient
communication overhead one way that
almost any business can be made more
efficient is to cut down on
communication overhead this is a term I
got from the personal MBA by Josh
Kaufman it means the amount of time and
therefore money that is wasted on
unnecessary emails and Skype calls I
advise avoiding clients that are intent
on having long Skype meetings that
discuss small orders and trying to keep
email chatter to a minimum wherever
possible in fact I actually personally
choose to use agents and intermediaries
to cut down on this first they take a
cut of my profits but he also fined me
the work and handle all complaints as
well as negotiations etc that means I
can just focus on work and avoid wasting
my mental energy despite giving away
some of my profits per job I ultimately
earn more by being a complete more work
go to market strategy the go-to-market
strategy simply means finding where
people who want your services are likely
to congregate from web design
copywriting video editing coding and
more it's common to find work from sites
like up work and freelancer problem is
that you're competing with a lot of
other professionals here I'm going to be
forced to work for that websites
guidelines often to your detriment
so I'm actually encourage you to record
your screen for instance so that clients
can see exactly what you're doing
throughout your day which is highly
invasive so ask instead where do the
people you're selling to hang out
what do they read it could be a
subreddit it could be a forum it could
be an industry magazine maybe it means
working with an influencer in that niche
and getting them to give you a shout out
I sell most of my services via webmaster
forums and via agencies this is free
it's simple and it's provided me with
steady work now for almost 18 years I
give plenty more tips and where you can
find work of all kinds in the book know
your worth building a basic website
using WordPress is an incredibly easy
task that will take about a day for
anyone with even moderate tech skills
nevertheless big companies pay thousands
of dollars of this work because they
don't know any different if you try and
sell them a web design for Less don't
presume you're offering an inferior
product and they'll likely pass you over
to choose the more expensive option that
normally means a big company or agency
that isn't quite as efficient as you are
because you're so much more lean point
is that it doesn't matter if your skill
seems easy it's the knowledge gap and
the value that they get out of it that
should determine what you're charging so
make sure you know your Worth and don't
be afraid to ask for it become a
superstar
that said if you do try and sell your
skills to a big corporation you're
probably still going to be passed up in
favor of more established and stuffy
business thus you'll be forced to go
after the small fry and compete with
smaller individuals instead until your
business plan is ridiculous
so as an individual what can you do to
fix the situation and compete with
bigger companies the answer is to become
an online superstar and to build your
own personal brand you do this by taking
on high-profile jobs to build an amazing
portfolio you do it by filling out your
CV by continuing to learn and train
yourself you can also create a blog or a
blog we discuss your skills try to
imagine the procurement department at
the company hiring your work discussing
your merits versus the web design
company or programming agency that
you're competing with if you're just
someone they found on upwork then you're
not going to compete with the
professional outfit but if you've worked
on projects for Google and Facebook if
you've built your own highly successful
app if you've authored books and if
you've got your own coding blog with an
audience of hundreds of thousands
suddenly you're a contender and you can
charge the really big bucks so if you
found any of these tips helpful or
interesting then you should get a lot of
value out of the book there I go into
much more depth regarding how to set up
a business after transition safely from
regular work and how to build a
resilient
that provides stable and growing income
I also go into some depth regarding the
market forces that gave birth to the gig
economy and how it's likely to evolve
and grow in exciting ways in the future
the short version this type of work is
becoming increasingly common and so by
figuring out your place in this gig
economy now you can gain the upper hand
on the competition and lift the
lifestyle that you really want
so thanks ton for watching guys hope you
found this video useful and interesting
if you did then of course check out the
book but also subscribe to the channel
where you'll find much more on building
a business on productivity on
self-improvement also fitness brain
training all that usual stuff if that
sounds good
then thanks a ton for watching stay
tuned and bye for now